hello everyone and welcome to the active
inference lab
today it is august 9th 2021 and we're
here in guest stream number 8.1
with mark miller and guests so this is
going to be an awesome presentation
followed by a discussion so if you have
any questions during the presentation
please put them in the live chat and
we'll make sure to ask the panel at the
end of the presentation so thanks again
to all of our great guests for coming on
and please take it away thank you
excellent thanks for that daniel okay
i'm just going to share my screen
oh can you uh turn on screen sharing for
me on your side
um
it's under the advanced so at the bottom
where it says share screen there should
be a little little arrow and click that
there should be an advanced feature and
then should say allow got it
okay go for it yeah that's it uh-huh
great how's that can you just see my
slide does that look right
excellent great okay well daniel thanks
thanks so much man for the invitation to
come and give a talk i mean we've been
trying to get we've been trying to find
an opportunity to speak together for you
know a couple of months now well since i
moved to japan so i'm excited to be here
and i'm excited to be talking about this
topic which we're um we're really
excited about it's a new paper that
actually julian kiverstein who's here
right now and myself and eric reitfeld
um have a preprint out right now in the
the paper title title of predictiveness
of happiness and well-being we're also
anticipating that um inez hippolyto and
laura sinbad smith will be here this
evening lars has had a slight emergency
so um he's on the road but we're hoping
he'll be able to call in um because
actually the work that uh we feature in
this paper
it builds on or it's really closely
related with the research that anez and
lars are doing so the idea was that
we're gonna be able to get um we're
gonna be able to really talk to them
about their individual portions so
hopefully they're on the stream by the
time we hit that place and uh if it
turns out that they're not that's okay
we can just go through and then we can
chat at the end um if you don't know me
uh my name is mark miller
i'm an assistant professor at the
university of hokkaido um in their
center for human nature artificial
intelligence and neuroscience and i am
uh an active inference researcher
right so
let's see
um
right so i guess probably lots of people
who are listening to the stream tonight
and definitely the guests who are here
right now hey anez great you made it
right on
um know that um recently there's been a
huge amount of research coming out
that's linking um using the active
inference framework in order to
investigate all sorts of
psychopathologies you know mostly
finding a home in computational
psychiatry circles but really we're
we're seeing active inference accounts
come up
you know relating to depression and
addiction and ocd and schizophrenia and
dissoci dissociative disorders and all
sorts
and while there is
this sort of active inference boom right
now in relationship to computational
psychiatry and
in particular psychopathology we're not
seeing any work really
talking about um how we might apply
active inference frameworks to the
theoretical and formal approach of
discussing things like well-being so you
know all those topics that would
naturally fit in something like a
positive psychology are still primarily
being overlooked although you know um in
all fairness we are starting to see it
come up at the edges because we're
starting to see people talk about the
benefits of hallucinogens and also the
benefits of meditation so that was part
of our motivation in writing this paper
was to see if there was anything
interesting to say in a positive account
yeah not just the negative account but
the positive account
um but the other reason why we decided
to write this paper was because
actually julian and eric and i have
written a series of papers now on
psychopathologies in particular using
the active inference framework so we
have papers out now on um depression and
mood disorders and addiction and
depersonalization and ocd
and we started to see that there were
some shared characteristics between
these various psychopathologies if you
look at them through the sort of
computational lens of active inference
and seeing those
shared characteristics
sort of started providing
we think clues about you know what might
be going right when a human is happy
healthy and well and that's what our
paper is about and that's what this
guest stream will be about as well
looking a little bit more at what some
of the predictive dynamics might be that
are underlying um subjective happiness
and overall well-being and of course
it's a big topic so we're not trying to
exhaust you know and try to exhaust the
whole of what well-being would be but
rather just taking a sort of first step
to see if we can work out some of the
some of the points that might be
interesting so since i have these lovely
people here tonight with me um i've
decided to make my presentation
relatively short um i hope it won't be
any more than sort of 30 minutes all
said and um i'm going to pitch it at a
relatively high level of abstraction
because i think there's like a number of
nice moves i'd like to give to the
audience here tonight to sort of provoke
research and provoke some ideas and um
if you're interested more in the nitty
gritty um we have the paper out in
pre-print so you're more than welcome to
go and actually check out the paper and
of course if any questions come up we
can talk about that as well
great
okay so
so i think a sort of natural place to
start thinking about the relationship
between active inference and well-being
is to think about optimality um in
cognitive neuroscience and psychology
today well-being is often spoken of as a
form of optimal psychological
functioning um but what exactly optimal
means is not very well explained usually
or at least it's
underdeveloped and of course
as a free energy
principle and active inference framework
researcher when you look at that you the
first thing i thought was well there's a
natural way to sort of be thinking about
optimality um in terms of the active
inference framework right free energy
minimization over the long run
approximates optimal asian inference
right that is sort of bayesian inference
is a form of optimal belief updating so
um
that fact in some way already gives us
you know it gives the free energy
principle in the active inference
framework you might think a sort of
normativity already you know predictive
systems tend to create or strive towards
an optimal fit between their
phenotypical self-organization and the
sort of statistical regularities that
they encounter in their environments
so
um we think that an important part of
well-being
from this perspective is going to have
something to do with being a good
predictor of the sort of hidden causes
so that's both in the environment and
inside the agent of the sort of sensory
states that we tend to encounter and of
course that crucially relies on our
being able to optimally update our
generative model in ways that are
life-sustaining and flourishing inducing
and i don't think that that's an
incredible stretch just as an opening
gamut um you know we know that
well-being is closely related with
health in various um
various layers of health you know mental
health and emotional health and physical
health
and good predictors they tend to
self-organize in ways that allow them to
maintain homeostasis across various
contexts and over the long term
right so um oh and you know and sort of
best of all um if we think along these
lines which i think could be fruitful
lines to think along than we have at our
disposal as lots of um the listeners
today already know this sort of ever
evolving and ever-growing mathematical
suite to help us describe what is a good
model what's a good model all about so
that's our starting point our starting
point was to think well maybe well-being
could be discussed broadly
as a kind of optimal updating yeah and
the goodness the goodness of the
generative model that the agent uses to
form beliefs and control their actions
in life-sustaining ways over the long
term
okay so that's a good start
and i think it fits very nicely with
what we already know about lots of
psychopathologies in particular that
psychopathologies are characterized by
sub-optimal beliefs and the sorts of
behaviors that come from having
sub-optimal beliefs um depression is a
good example it's just one out of a hat
though really i think if you look at any
psychopathology you're going to find
some sort of bad belief is at play at
some level of the hierarchy i think
depression is a nice example you know
recent accounts of depression and not
just from the act of inference camp um
are highlighting the role that rigid
beliefs about one's inability to manage
the complexities of their life including
especially the social complexities of
their life is playing a major role in
depressive symptoms and we've written a
paper on this um pretty recently
and um in that paper we using the active
inference framework we argued that when
an agent is met with enough persistent
volatility then they can eventually
develop a high level prior
about their own
high level prior belief
about their own um inability to manage
volatility and when you get uh that high
level prior installed something
pretty nasty can happen right um the
system a predictive system then starts
selectively sampling the world to try to
confirm that hypothesis and in fact it
down regulates any sort of counter
evidence that goes against that deep
prior that deep pathological prior so so
that even when the situation changes you
know if the agent finds themselves in
more positively predictable situations
uh they tend to hold on to that belief
in volatility and that's really the what
we think is the pathological moment so
another way of saying that is
an agent at least a depressed agent yeah
has uh become overly confident that it
is uncertain it's overly confident about
being uncertain we're not the only
people who've said that clerking
colleagues have written a fantastic
paper um definitely check it out if you
don't know it and in that they come to
the same conclusions they write in this
sense we might conjecture that major
depression occurs when the brain is
certain that it will encounter an
uncertain environment
okay and um as we all know you know due
to the central role that prediction
plays in sculpting our experience and
directing our behaviors of course as
soon as we have a high level bias like
this installed um then it has tremendous
power to
produce exactly the outcomes that would
um that would confirm those biases it's
one of the problems of being a
predictive agent you know the predictive
system is really good for lots of things
but one of the problems is there's this
sort of deep self-fulfilling prophecy
that can occur okay
um
the rigidity of these bad beliefs is
especially important here and it comes
up again when we start thinking about
what well-being might be um you know
there's mounting evidence that cognitive
rigidity you know the sort of stickiness
of bad beliefs um but they're a basic
feature of psychopathologies and in fact
you know um some people are even saying
that it might be the root cause of all
psychopathologies and um i don't think
we disagree um there's a nice aeon
article about this if you uh if you're
interested in that point and i think i
might just uh take a take a little break
there and hand it over to anez um and
this hippolyto has a really just a
fantastic forthcoming paper coming out
that everyone should be excited to be
reading which offers um a really
beautiful computationally rich
account of how
insulated internal states yeah when
these bad beliefs sort of get stuck and
then they resist updating how that
creates um the sorts of pathological
belief systems the pathological
behaviors that we see in psychopathology
so um if it's okay and as i'm just gonna
stop share and let you maybe talk a
little bit about insulated bad beliefs
and then i'll pick it up from here and
keep going on to well-being you know is
that okay
yes for sure um hi everyone can you hear
me and see me
yeah okay great so first of all thanks
so much for mark for inviting me to be
here and it's always such a pleasure to
be here with daniel uh for these
wonderful sessions and uh hi julian
uh very nice to see you as well
so i'll just now share my screen
if i think that's possible yeah
let me see
okay so for some reason i'm not able to
share my screen
i
think it should maybe try again
okay
no it doesn't go through for some reason
uh
strange it works for me fine
i have no idea
we could go for a uh
an audio
thought or you can try to share it
later let me just leave and come back if
that's okay maybe that's good you know
the trick
um this is uh this is this is the new
world of technology isn't it you have to
do everything on the fly you have to do
everything on the fly and be willing to
adapt
i i have one interim question
yeah please yeah i hit it
were you working on active inference or
interested in those approaches and then
came to be studying
psychopathology or just well-being more
broadly or was it the other direction
like which way did you come at this
intersection from
yeah you're right and um it started the
other way around so um in my masters in
which julian was my advisor at the
university of edinburgh in 2010
um the last chapter of my senior thesis
was a proposal so i was working on
empathy looking at um um you know
philosophy and cognitive science of
empathy looking at dynamic systems
theories of emotion the last chapter was
on predictive processing and active
inference and then i got to do my phd
with andy clark
specifically on active inference and
then it grew out of doing that into
psychopathology yeah we got it very good
we got it excellent we got it some
technical difficulties but uh we are now
good okay all right you can see it fine
yeah yep nice work thanks and let's
continue perfect
okay so um all right so um yes this work
is on uh uh what we call psychotic macro
blankets and this is a something that
i've been working on uh for the last few
months with two different groups
applying this to uh different um
uh two different things so one
specifically schizophrenia specifically
and the other one is um
disembodiment so what i thought i would
do here today would be to do like sort
of like a combination between um the two
so that we get like a bigger picture of
what uh we have in mind with them with
uh with applying this particular
framework
so um
yeah so um
let me just uh give some like framing
about uh where this comes from and uh
why and to motivate it a little bit so
that was the parts from this concept
that mark also just mentioned the
self-organization which is super
relevant to these things that we are
talking about when we refer to
well-being and mental health and all of
that um
and as a few words about that it's an
emergence of order from disorder and
specifically without an intervention
from the external intervention that is
external to the system
um and then what is important here for
us is to think of self-organization as a
pattern or an arrangement that gives
rise to a specific way in which the
system is self-producing and
self-distinguishing and here and not to
the inactivist literature
so but the idea here that the
fundamental concept is the
self-organizing pattern that that comes
up
um
this is why why are we talking about
that because we want to look at how
the systems or the organisms as a whole
are
interacting with the environment in a
way that has been called in embodied
literature as a tournament with the
environment right
so the idea there is that these
organisms or the systems are a tune with
their environment and uh in a way that
they will show a certain specific
pattern um or part of the arrangement
that will be distinct from for example
systems that are not attuned to the
environment and this is very well known
in
the whole bulk of literature in this
embodiment and phenomenology
so uh the idea that we want to pursue
here is actually relating to a little
bit too complex systems theory in which
we want to say that
this differentiation between embodiment
and disembodiment are different patterns
it doesn't mean that the system
that the system
that is not adjusted to the environment
should be considered as disordered but
instead that it has a different kind of
order
right
so he would be sort of like rejecting a
little bit the computationalist accounts
of psychopathology as simply a disorder
a disorder or an illness and
opening up a little bit of more like a
broad scope or spectrum of um to talk
about mental health
um so then if we set up things like that
then uh what needs to be explained is
how uh this self-organizing behavior of
situated organisms come to be ordered in
a certain way rather than another and
then we'll be uh now talking about uh
mental health
so um then we think that active
inference is um a very interesting and
useful
tool precisely to
think about uh this uh self-organization
and the patterns that come from the
self-organization
um we think about um active inference as
a model of
uh leaving things adjust to the
environment and we all know what active
inference is so i'm just gonna highlight
what is relevant here for us in terms of
pattern dynamics
we think that it is a nice and cool
model that
when associated with tools such as macro
blankets or renormalization group it can
be applied to many different scales of
self-organizing activity and that's
where we find all of these patterns of
our interest of our scientific interest
so it is useful to explain um these
gradients spectrums of kinds of patterns
of order in self-organizing systems so
just highlighting these ideas
um so we take it as a model um in this
case so it means that we are not
committing to the
to the realist view of
that let's say that the phenomenon
studied under active inference
ontologically possess or leverages the
conceptual tool but that the tool is
really important and useful for us to
understand uh certain phenomenons in
this case particularly what you want to
understand is this embodiment
right so we all know active inference
but again let me just highlight uh just
some important points to understand than
the psychotic markov blankets later on
so um
here the idea is that self-organizing
self-producing self-distinguishing
system will correspond to the internal
states which affect and which effects
and affect and are affected by the
environment and the external states
via a set of other states such as the
active and the sensory states
active and sensory states are then
constructed as influencing one another
giving rise to a certain pattern of
self-organization and this is what's
going to be relevant for later on
so in a way what we want to say is that
well an adjusted system
that self-organizes is a system that um
minimizes the free energy which we all
know can also be understood as
uncertainty or entropy and so on right
but an adjusted system would be
something like that
a system that is just well adjusted to
its environment and for technicalities
obviously there are these references on
the bottom
now moving on to this embodiment and
then later on applying we want to apply
this
active inference strategy to
further highlight or understand what is
going on with this embodiment um
just a few words about the disembodiment
literature
so the idea is that comes from
phenomenology and a little bit from
existentialist philosophy and the idea
is that the primary experience of the
body is the body experienced as a
subject and this is really crucial
um
the thing is that this experience of the
body as a subject can be lost and
in which case the body is inspected as
an object more like a side of scientific
interest and here is what uh the
literature says that that's when this
embodiment comes up is when the body all
of a sudden ceases to be experienced as
a subject and is now inspected as an
object
so what happens is uh in exploring and
interacting with the local environment
we usually typically we do not attend to
our body we just like take it for
granted got our body that allows us to
access move around interact explore the
world through our body
and it is not until we cannot do these
things or something is wrong that we
will direct our awareness towards the
body
and then the body becomes salient as an
object of inquiry and it's right here at
this point where we find this embodiment
it's when we cannot um explore or
interact with the world as one would
like would like
so in a way we can um
distinguish embodiment and disembodiment
by saying uh for example or just
highlighting these features of course
the literature is vast but i think that
these are the ones that work for us here
um embodiment is an attunement with the
environment that is allowed or enabled
by having an experience of the body as a
subject
um and that gets us attuned um to the
environment through a bodily
self-awareness or something that there
is a bodily self-awareness that is
that is uh
felt
then this embodiment on the other on the
other hand is a disatonment with the
environment because there is a loss of
the body as a subject body becomes an
object
there's a disatonment and a diminished
body awareness so this comes from the
literature
and it is interesting for us here why
because
then there's been these links that have
been made between psychopathology and
psychedelics and disembodiment as in
this embodiment being something that is
reported in different psychopathology
such as schizophrenia the
personalization
even major depression
or other
psychopathologies that involve
rumination
and another very important thing is that
this embodiment also occurs or is what
is reported in the encyclopedias intake
and
this has been um even more relevant uh
studying this embodiment precisely in
the psychedelic renaissance that we are
witnessing today and also another point
that i want to make uh just here sounds
like in brackets
is just that disembodiment does not
necessarily need to be a bad thing right
we usually put things in
good or bad right or wrong but it
doesn't need to be a bad thing because
if we do get some therapeutical effects
um positive effects from psychedelics
this precisely by having this
disembodied experience so it's just a
different way of interacting with the
world and that's why we want to pursue
less of a disorder way and much more of
a there's a spectrum of different
patterns of interaction with the world
right
okay so just that note um
then um i want to look at this
embodiment um
and how we can use active inference to
understand this embodiment in two ways
one is the psycho the psychology of this
embodiment so how that disappointment is
felt psychologically and the other one
is the neurobiology of this embodiment
so as we have said uh this embodiment is
the loss of the body as a subject which
is replaced by
uh some form of
intellectual effort so imagine that you
now don't have these broadly access to
the world that is not possible because
that's exactly what has been lost by
psychopathology or psychedelics intake
and many other things right so then
try to cope and compensate by literally
engaging in making inferences about the
state of affairs so here we could use a
little bit of the literature and
sophisticated active inference which is
this conscious reasoning and planning
and policy selection that you engage now
with having lost these access to the
world through the body
now our hypothesis is that the issue is
that in this disembodied because we all
engage in sophisticated active inference
that's all fine
um the difficulty is that in the case of
this embodiment um experience this
inference is insulated is isolated
because what has been lost is the body
access to the world
so then what happens is um so uh we
would have something that looks like
this so we all know this um this scheme
here right and what we want to say is
that what is lost now is the
influences between sensory and active
states and let me guide you through it
so um let's just uh
focus on the figure for now so we have
internal states as being disembodied
reasoning so a subject that has lost
this access or bodily access to the
world because the body is not felt as a
subject so we've got this disembodied
reasoning as internal states and then we
have external states as the environment
where that that the subject wants to
explore and interact with
and then we have a sensory state
the environmental co-constraints so
these aspects that should influence uh
the subject right and then as active
straight states we have the effectivity
as um the ways in which the subject can
affect and being effect and be affected
by the environment
but what has been lost
here is
that there is an unbalance between
sensory and active states
so for one
active states are not sensitive to
sensoristics
right so
it is this effectivity or this
possibility of being affected by the
environment that is not possible why
because
the access through the sub the body as a
subject has been lost in this
psychopathology or psychedelics as that
we label as disembodiment experience
so um as a coping mechanism what is
going to happen is there will be an
increase of activity of the activity of
active states by increasing the issuing
of inferences about the world so i do
not understand
what is going on
but i'm going to continue to think about
it and make and and develop theories
about what is going on
the problem is that we can we all engage
in these developing theories and
inferences about what we think is the
likelihood of the state of affairs the
situation here in this embodiment is
that these inferences are disembodied
so they tend to be false beliefs
and that's because of the insulation of
internal states
what does this mean this means that
there is not um so the access that we
had
with the world through our lived body
is what is lost so then the subject in a
situation where um the only hope is to
increase in increase active states
to make more inferences about the world
to cope with that loss
and then tendency is to have false
beliefs that's when we start entering
the realm of psychopathology and
psychosis
so in these disembodied cases uh this is
actually a very important point because
one could say okay so then the problem
is the is on the level of reasoning so
on the level of for example of the
internal states as we have set up here
no the problem is not on the level of
the internal states reasoning is fine
the inference mechanisms are working
perfectly fine the subject can engage in
in reasoning
it can make
inferences the problem is inside the
markov blanket the problem is in the
unbalance that there is between active
and sensory states because those are the
ones that are supposed to
directly influence one another such that
indirectly there's a connection between
internal and external states but it is
this um direct influence between sensory
and active states
that is problematic they are not
communicating well they are not
influencing uh themselves or each other
in a balanced way
um in a sense and balanced in the sense
that active states become super active
and sensory states um cannot influence
active states so then what we get we get
to this idea of a psychotic markov
blanket which is if we have this sort of
arrangement where there's a problem
between the balance of the strength of
influences between sensory and active
states then we have
a problem of the generation of false
beliefs
the problem being that these beliefs
that are issued by active states they
cannot be updated by the world because
it is precisely this access to the world
that has been lost lost by virtue of
having lost
the body as a subject
so then um
because of this uh this achievement that
we can actually
explain as what is appearing inside the
marco blanket
the reasoning subject makes inference
about inferences about world but um
these reasoning occurs from within the
lack of the experience of the body as a
subject so it occurs in an insulated
manner and this is consistent actually
um with a long-standing literature and
phenomenology of psychosis
um where uh the subjects and sisters a
bunch of children on psychosis linked to
solipsistic behavior
um solid existing uh drawing and
painting and also the philosophical idea
which is the philosophical idea that
only one's mind is sure to exist
and then some some reports that i find
quite interesting is uh uh some patients
who report i was no longer sure
that i was still the same person
i became one with other creatures or
objects i lost a sense of my own
boundaries
when i had an experience i often did not
know it was mine or the experience of
someone else so it is quite interesting
what can be
lost
when we lose these
body as a subject as it is developed in
phenomenology this also happens a little
bit in the personalization disorder um
for example showing this disembodiment
is achievement
when
making people feel estranged and
detached from their self body and the
world
okay so this is all i had on the
disembodied on the psychology of this
embodiment and now i'd like to turn to
the neurobiology and also in the end
apply the same framework now to the
neurobiology of um of
the underlying neurobiology of this
environment
so we think that applying the same
reasoning is
is consistent so this this achievement
that you were talking about felt at
agent level should also be expected at
the
neurological state so that's our
hypothesis right
so now we think that there are two
places there are two good candidates for
perception and interception would be
good candidates um super perception as a
system underlying movement and location
of the body in the environment as well
as interception as the system
responsible for homeostasis these are
good candidates we think um for the
neurobiology biology of this general
disorder that is felt in this embodiment
um
so proprioceptive and interceptive
systems um just like any situated
organism can be conceived as
self-organizing systems so we apply
exactly the same principle as we would
apply
to the
agent as a self-organizing system
so the question then that we had is what
is the factor that is at the basis of
this of a neurobiological pattern
underlying proprioception and
interception that will show this small
adjustment to the local environment so
if we expect the same sort of mechanism
or organization
dynamics as to the whole
agent and that we were just talking
about then how are we going to find this
out as well in the neurobiology
so we think that
just like in psychological experience of
this embodiment where the agent becomes
insulated from the world and in this
case we say by virtue of losing the body
as a subject the answer will reside in
biological insulation
um now i'm going to focus now on
interception because i don't have time
to also cover proprioception um and i
think that this does give us here some
very very cool insights so um
i'm going to uh focus now on the work uh
brought by baritone siemens on
interceptive predictions in the brain
and they have a vertical model which
they call embodied predictive
interception coding model
and well the goal there is to integrate
an anatomical model of corticocortical
connections with beijing active
inference principles and they propose a
very cool thing which is that a granular
visceral motor cortexes contribute to
interception by issuing interception
predictions
so more specifically what they want to
say is that the granular limbic regions
that regulate visceral motor of the
body's um internal milia that is the
visceral motor cortexes so this is their
focus and where do you think they will
find the interceptive uh system and
where they apply the model
now um so you can see the agranular
cortex here uh on the left and uh one
very interesting thing that i'm just
gonna draw your attention to and then if
you feel uh that you'd like to read this
super interesting paper then um please
go for it but i just want to draw your
attention to the fact that on the left
side you have the a granular cortex and
there's one thing that is missing from
the a-granular cortex as
opposed to
the these granular and the granular
cortis so what is missing is the layer 4
and what happens with that is that there
won't be you cannot see
there any prediction error neurons so
that's pretty cool because that will uh
give us
an idea that there is no prediction
error neurons in the a granular cortex
um so just
i'm just going to leave that um out
there and um just moving uh forward to
just like a understanding like the very
cheese of the embodied predative
interceptive coding model
um they claim that there is an
interceptive system in the brain in
which a granular cortices sends visceral
motor predictions to the body and
transmits interceptive predictions about
the visceral sensory consequences of
those predictions
so they also tell us that adrenal are
visceral motor cortexes estimate the
balance between the autonomic metabolic
and immunological resources that are
available to the body and the predicted
requirements of the body based on past
experience
right so this is going to be very
important for us
because
a chronic imbalance
on those things that i was just
mentioning can be which can be caused by
constantly predicting the need for more
metabolic energy to meet the demands for
stressors
can produce the well-known depression
related disruption
and it can also eventually down regulate
uh
provoke a down regulation of
hypothalamus or
hpa axis negative feedback loops
resulting in chronic hyper cortisolemia
and in turn can also promote
pro-inflammatory state so this is like
some of like the problems of having
an imbalance on the level of the
autonomic metabolic and immunological
resources which is what the
interoceptive system should be able to
do is to give us that nice balance right
so then applying exactly the same um
the same framework the same model that
we applied to the whole
body this embodiment or the generalized
feel of this embodiment that is vastly
described in the phenomenology
literature applying this to the
neurobiology of the interperceptive
system then what we get is something
that can be seen as like quite similar
an unbalance between sensory and active
state so let me just
guide through the figures so here in
this figure internal states are
interests are or correspond to the
interoceptive system and the external
stage the environment whichever um the
multi-scaled system that receptive
system is part of
and then we have active stages that a
granular quartus
that send visceral motor predictions and
then we have sensory stage stages the
requirements of the body given the
history that the body knows
to be
required for homeostasis so then in this
sense what we would have is that active
states are not sensitive to sensory
states so even though active states can
become uh as a coping mechanism much
more active and send much more
predictions about what is going on
what's the state of affairs
um because i'm not receiving any
information from the requirements of the
body so the sensory states
so what will happen then because of this
insulation
is that a false belief is going to be
generated
so this will correspond to a constantly
prediction of the need for more
metabolic energy to meet the demands of
the stressors so in this sense we have
here another case of what we call a
psychotic markov blanket why is it
psychotic because it delivers if there
is this lack or this imbalance between
sensory states or the
influences between sensory states and
active states then what we should expect
is a degeneration of a false belief and
we can also expect that at a
neurobiological level which is also
supported by empirical evidence
so yeah this is what i wanted to say uh
just thinking um thanking these uh
collaborators here that have been
thinking about and guiding me through as
well these ideas
thank you ness really
interesting stuff so i guess we'll
return to
mark and then anybody is
yep anyone's free to ask a question in
the live chat and i'm writing things
down and then after this
second piece of the presentation we'll
have a discussion so thanks again go for
it mark
yeah that was great thank you so much
wow it's so interesting and i haven't
heard some of your stuff about
disembodiment yet and you know also this
is a research program that i'm extremely
interested in so uh i'll be picking your
brain at the end of the q a and also
after after this event um what might
what wasn't made obvious in anez's talk
but i think is implied is that the
stickiness the stickiness of these
belief systems and what's helping them
become insulated is a story about how
precision is being estimated and how
precision is being deployed that's
surely one of the mechanisms that is
creating an imbalance between active and
sensory states
so you know
how precision is estimated is really the
agent's ability to assess the
uncertainty of its own priors
and when that's working right then those
estimations should result in appropriate
model updating you know you shouldn't
get stuck in an insulated in an
insulated situation but rather you
should know wow that's not working out
the right way and so appropriate
updating should occur um and we know
that like
maladaptive precision estimation is
disastrous right and we're seeing it
everywhere in the psychopathology
literature today you know schizophrenic
delusion is being um characterized as
too little precision on sensory data
which is putting this heavy emphasis on
just top-down predictions so that's why
you're seeing the world in a way that
isn't being anchored by what's really
happening and of course asd is a little
bit the flip right too much precision on
prediction errors creates a lot of a lot
of volatility and a little bit
difficulty um establishing good high
level predictions
um
and as a quick side note you know the
the kind of insulated insulated um
outcomes that create these maladaptive
uh self-organizing styles they can occur
in lots of ways right so for instance
yeah so addictive substances is one good
way right addictive substances impact
directly precision estimation machinery
right in the way that the addictive
substance engages the dopaminergic
system so addictive substances are
setting precision outright in a way so
no wonder they can create these sort of
sub-optimal styles
but societal expectations do the same
sort of thing you know sub optimally
pinning precision on
expectations about success for example
you know um so you can have cultural
pinning of precision that you should
achieve a certain level of success in
your life and you know we have deep
running relationships between
perfectionism and depression for example
and again for exactly the same reason
that anes said overly high precision on
some sort of expectation would lead to a
constant
pervasive background error as you're not
hitting that high level of expectation
and then just like um feldman barrett
suggests in simmons you have an hpa flip
because the system just doesn't have
unlimited resources um and then the one
that i'm most interested in today
actually is social media which is
turning out to be a like fantastic way
of bending our generative model into all
sorts of shapes that cause sub-optimal
outcomes right and that makes sense it's
just giving us wave after wave of um you
know misinformation through filtered
images and staged images and of course
social media platforms some social media
platforms function just like addictive
substances or like casinos in a way so
again they're
hijacking the precision system in just
the sorts of ways that cause these
problems okay
i just want to quickly summarize before
i go on to why what i think the natural
mechanisms that keep us out of these
problems are so
well-being as optimal model generation
importantly depends on correct and
flexible yeah not these stuck insulated
outcomes but correct and flexible
self-estimations of uncertainty so
that's precision assignments
um so misassigning precision to
prediction errors which can happen in
lots of ways especially in our in our
modern world um will inevitably lead to
sub-optimal styles of self-organization
sub-optimal generative models and with
that the production of pathological
beliefs and pathological behaviors and
um
so that's how it can go wrong or at
least that's the starting point it's one
of the ways that it can go wrong so
that's how it goes wrong then what is it
that ordinarily keeps us out of these
sorts of bad bootstraps these sorts of
insulated uh disharmonies between the
the system and the environment and one
answer that i like that we like as a
team it was given by alex chance and
colleagues er where they said that
optimal free energy minimizing agents
will benefit from striking a good
balance between pragmatic and epistemic
engagements okay so that is they don't
only act in a pragmatic way that is in
ways that they're highly confident will
reduce free energy over time because
they can be wrong that's part of the
take-home message from some of the
pathological self-organization styles
right they say that you should also a
good free energy minimizing system is
going to balance that against being
driven to epistemically explore and
forage for more information about how
the world works but also about how their
own model works and implied there is
that when they find important counter
evidence while they're out exploring
that they're willing to update their
model relative to that counter evidence
so then the question then if we buy that
and i i think i do buy that's one of the
ways that we stay out of these bad boot
straps and these sub-optimal styles of
interacting well how do we find that
right balance i think that's a good
question if we're gonna ask well how do
we live well what is well-being all
about how do we find that good balance
and the central way that we've been
arguing over a number of papers is that
we literally feel our way to that
balance and um that part of course is
predicated on everything working right
because if you have an affective
disorder then it's going to be exactly
that mechanism that's going to be
mis-tuned and of course we get all the
problems um that anna's just pointed out
so um in a series of recent papers we've
been exploring the suggestion that um
good precision assignment is going to
rely in part on the rate at which error
is being reduced so that's commonly
referred to as aerodynamics and um we're
increasingly not alone in this
conjecture um we have people like jeff
lee and corcelli who gave the first
paper on this and of course vanda cruz
and then it was beautifully formalized
by casper hesp and colleagues
um so if you want to look really at the
nitty gritty of this that's definitely
the paper to check out and if you want
to see a great paper on the
computational bits of this you should
see casper's talk it's there on the
slide it's fantastic so um the idea um
uh the idea has developed that these
aerodynamics yeah the changes in the
rate at which error is reduced are
registered by the organism as affective
states and um if we think of an agent's
performance in reducing error in terms
of a slope yeah that plots the various
speeds that prediction error is being
accommodated relative to our
expectations then we can think that
positively and negatively balanced
affective states are a reflection of
better than or worse than slopes of
error reduction so um that is just to
say we feel good when we're doing better
than expected at reducing error relative
to expectations yeah better than
expected and we feel bad when we do
worse than expected at reducing um
prediction error and
these embodied aerodynamics are
important drivers of precision
estimation it turns out and i think that
makes sense of course right because
unexpected increases or decreases in
volatility relative to your model is
important information for how you should
set precision on your beliefs about
action policies right so unexpected
decreases in the rate at which error is
being reduced tells you that your action
policy isn't working the way that you
thought it was going to work which means
you should obviously reduce your
confidence in that action policy and the
other way as well right if you're
unexpectedly doing better at reducing
prediction error relative to some policy
then you should up your confidence in
that policy
so the point being here is that
precision then isn't adjusted only based
on the amount of error or the amount of
error reduction but precision is also
being tuned
relative to the rates at which air is
being minimized over time
and um that feature of the active
inference framework gives us a rather
sexy account of momentary subjective
happiness which i think is so
interesting right um momentary subject
of happiness is the result of
unexpectedly reducing prediction error
and that feels good because we are
suddenly doing better than we thought we
would at getting a good predictive grip
on our environment which under normal
circumstances would usually mean that we
are staying healthy and we're staying
well and um juffley and corchelli's
graph makes that clear you know as free
energy is going up um you feel fear and
then you feel unhappy when it's super
high and then you feel hope when it
starts getting better and you feel happy
when uh error is being managed in an
extremely good way but actually it's not
only showing up in active inference
these ideas are being presented in um
in other camps as well rob rutledge is
of course the paradigmatic case um he
and his team have done a number of uh
brain imaging studies that have already
started to show the strong relationship
between subjective feelings of happiness
and doing better than expected in some
particular nation you can see on the
board behind rob there that's the
calculation for happiness which i think
is a bit of a cheeky way to go but i
think it's cool um and uh if you know
the maths then of course you're gonna
you're gonna know what's going on there
too
okay
now we get to the fun stuff this is the
last thing this is sort of we're coming
into the last stretch here's the fun
stuff so
we think that the same machinery that
underlies momentary subjective happiness
is also going to play a leading role in
helping us tend towards optimality and
to avoid these sort of sub-optimal
styles of self-organization so we think
it's going to play a special role in an
active inference account of what it
means to be well um to see
why aerodynamics play that role
we just have to ask ourselves well where
are the best slopes to be found and the
answer is the best slopes are found at
the edge of our own predictive
capabilities right between what's known
and highly reliable and what's unknown
and potentially more optimal and when
it's all working right
aerodynamics naturally move us out to
that edge right where errors are neither
so complex that we can't learn anything
from them nor too easily predictable
that there's no more epistemic value and
really the best slope is going to be
right there at the edge of your own
capabilities and you know that's not a
provocative that's not a provocative
idea we see that everywhere in the
curiosity literature um we know that
babies are attracted to medium amounts
of complexity not too well known not too
volatile we see it in mice put them in a
maze with varying rooms of uh grades of
complexity and the mouse will tend to
hang out in the room that's just above
its comfortability and um and you know
we're already building um adaptive and
effective robots using these ideas so
this isn't this isn't a far out idea
so important for our current discussion
is that
in order to make the most
of those good slopes that are right at
the edge of our own capability a
predictive system must be
sometimes willing to disrupt
its own
fixed point attractors yeah so it must
be willing to go beyond its habitual
policies to go beyond its extremely
well-known ways of self-organizing
beyond its own homeostatic set points
even right and that's one of the roles
that aerodynamics should play when
everything is working right when it's
going well and you're on a good slope of
error reduction then you should be
motivated to continue along that path
but when the niche
thesis to give you productive prediction
errors
then the negative valence that comes up
that signals to the system that it's
time to destroy
some of these fixed point attractors in
favor of more wandering policies more
explorative styles and i mean if you
want to see that in technical terms um
just check out uh fristen breaks beer
and deco that's the paper to go to so
agents that use aerodynamics in this way
to set precision on action policies
they're going to avoid getting stuck
in any one fixed attractor basin for too
long right they'll instead tend to exist
in more meta-stable states more often
they're going to be poised they're going
to be optimally poised in some way
between exploiting already existing off
action policies and performing action uh
information seeking epistemic actions
that reduce uncertainty
and that metastable poise
um
actually grants all sorts of fitness
advantages over
strictly ordered or more chaotic systems
at least in our kind of environment and
that's something that's very well known
in the dynamic systems literature so
again this isn't a very provocative
claim here um and it's precisely because
those sorts of systems have an optimal
balance between you know what you might
think of as efficiency and degeneracy
another way of saying that is um they're
set up to respond efficiently um to
particular contexts those contexts that
are highly predictable but they're also
remaining open to exploring and growing
in a wide variety of other possibilities
okay so notice then that um for a free
energy minimizing system in our kind of
environment
flourishing is not about avoiding errors
i know that's starting to be more
popular but i think it's a really good
point to like hit right on the head
it doesn't flourish by avoiding all
errors
it flourishes by selectively sampling
the right errors
and i think that's so cool like if that
wasn't immediately obvious if you're
still not like you're still not really
catching that point then i think it's
it's a good point to catch soon um
what matters for flourishing for a free
energy minimizing system in our kind of
environment is that it gets the right
kinds of errors because the right kind
of errors into it and of course we know
that you know like outside of the model
it only sounds weird i think inside the
model if you're in that camp outside of
the model we all we already know that
you know overly sterilized environments
make children sick
overly simplified cities make people
depressed like we know too little
volatility um causes problems for
complex self-organizing systems like us
again i don't think it's
such a provocative claim although it can
sound provocative from inside the active
inference framework maybe so finding the
right sorts of volatility and the suite
of cognitive emotional mechanisms that
keep us in touch
with that good volatility uh we think
that that's going to play center stage
in any account of well-being if we're
going to look at it through the active
inference lens and we've done a little
bit of work on this already this is our
aeon article where we do this in a sort
of popular way um if you want to check
it out the title of the article is the
value of uncertainty
good okay uh
last little bit and then we're done oh
so
um in and now we're going to come into
the most speculative part of the idea
and so then we'll stop and then we can
we can talk about it and see where it
goes so in the literature on well-being
um researchers tend to congregate in a
couple of big camps um and two of the
most popular camps are thinking about
well-being in terms of feeling good
that's the hedonic camp and people who
think that well-being is about being
good and that's the eudaimonia camp and
actually those go all the way back to
aristotle featured here as the cool guy
in the glasses so we speculate in our
paper
that actually we might be able to map
those two subjective momentary
subjective happiness and overall
flourishing being a good sort of
predictor on two forms of aerodynamics
um
a local form of aerodynamics and a
global form of aerodynamics
and we think that there's an uh good
reason
to start thinking about how we might
distinguish between local and global
aerodynamics um
because for instance think about video
game design okay so a well-crafted video
game
could be highly tailored in such a way
that it provides you with just the right
evolving changes
to keep you continually making learning
progress relative to the games you're
going to keep finding those good slopes
and we all know you know good game
design does do that it keeps creating
these good slopes of air reduction so do
good casinos right um
but um just like with substance
addiction right you can get so immersed
in those local good slopes that um you
end up surfing them at the expense of
the other things that matter in your
life so you start neglecting your
friendships and your schoolwork and your
work um and your overall fitness okay so
while you're succeeding locally at the
game uh you're not flourishing overall
because in fact there's going to be
rising volatility
across all of these other domains that
you're temporarily not paying attention
to
right so sensitivity to global
aerodynamics would essentially amount to
being driven in ways that reflect
how well we're managing errors across
the various domains in our life and as
long as an agent was using those more
global
estimations of how well or poorly
they're doing over their various
concerns uh to adjust their precision
then you're going to have an agent who
tends to stay in touch and who tends to
move towards optimality relative to
those multiple cares and concerns so
you're not only improving locally but we
think that there's good reason to think
that we're also sensitive to how we're
improving overall and that's going to
play a special role in well-being in
particular and um
that makes
if that's right if we're right here then
that makes a really natural fit between
this computational work that we've been
interested in and more recent so-called
network accounts of well-being where
well-being is thought of as the result
of tending to a complex ecosystem of
positive states and positive
achievements so then global aerodynamics
would be crucial here we think to
staying in touch with those various
concerns
in the kinds of way that would allow you
as a whole
to tend towards a good overall optimal
shape um now like i said this is the
most speculative part of the talk nobody
has talked yet about thinking about
aerodynamics happening in a nested way
but i just want to say that we do have
good reason to be thinking along that
line it's unfortunate that lars isn't
here with us tonight because it
piggybacks on some of his deep
parametric modeling so i was hoping to
lay it off on him to really get into the
computational nitty-gritty of why we're
not just
pulling this out of a hat for you um but
we so we build up this idea
that he's already been developing um and
the idea is basically um
he uses a deep parametric model and you
can check out his paper on metacognition
um if there's a way that we can um link
this somewhere i can yeah we can okay
i'll send it to you afterwards um but he
ends up showing that you know there's
higher level policies that are governing
the allocation of precision on lower
level tasks and the kind of cool thing
about this deep parametric model is that
it becomes possible to appreciate
precisions over
those higher level policies over
precision allocation to particular tasks
so you get this sort of nested you get
this nested precision estimation where
at the lower level you have precession
precision being adjusted relative to a
particular task at a higher level you
have precision
adjustments that are also effective we
suspect uh being set over the policies
about how you deploy your precisions
over
all the things you care about so that
that better than or worse than the
global better than or worse then is
going to be all about are you doing
better than or worse than a deploying
precision across your various cares and
concerns not relative to some local
concern so then we think that what
breaks down an addiction in particular
is you start paying attention to
aerodynamics locally in the drug seeking
and taking behaviors and you actually
have a separation of context and we see
that in the brain right you see the
striatum pull apart from the
dorsolateral prefrontal cortex so the
more contextualizing parts of the brain
are no longer communicating in the same
sorts of ways they were before because
you have ultra high precision on these
local aerodynamics so they're good again
is a good example where we're going to
get an insulated sort of psychotic
markov blanket emerge because of an
overestimation of precision because the
the drugs of addiction are are
making that happen so lars and myself
are currently working on clarifying that
aspect of the model so look forward to
work soon on that um and we're looking
at how we might apply that model to
thinking about um meditative development
thinking about attending to attention
precision on precision modeling
precision um
and uh thinking about how those sorts of
mechanisms might help us have better
access to and be better guided by these
higher level precision tuning processes
um yeah so look forward to that and uh
maybe that'll be another thing we can
come on and uh talk about here on the
lab and then hopefully lars will be uh
not an emergency situation that time and
he can come on
great um
so that's probably enough for me up
maybe just as a final note before we
turn it over to q a i might just say
um the future directions for this are
plenty if you buy some of the mechanisms
that we've been thinking about right it
would be cool to start now thinking
about what sorts of endeavors encourage
or disrupt that sort of meta-stable
poise
right meditation hallucinogens
provocative art installations um you
know are they are they helping or
hindering
um can we foster these metastable states
you know and and how you so deep brain
stimulation looks like it's doing
something like this you're getting stuck
in a tractor basin an ocd deep brain
stimulation and julian can talk about
that if it's an interesting point
reopens up the field of affordances by
creating more dynamic neural um
ecosystems
what does this mean for how we structure
our environment if this is right if we
flourish by hanging out at the edge of
our own capabilities then what does that
mean for how we structure our
environment how should we build our
cities i mean abby tabber at um at bath
is doing incredible work on this
thinking about how we might structure
our cities in ways that are
good for us and actually they turn out
to be sort of paradoxically not making
the city easier for us but making it
more challenging getting more diversity
more art installations more guerrilla
gardening uh things because actually the
more complexity we have actually the
better we are as individuals and of
course the biggest thing i'm working on
right now here at uh hokkaido university
is what does that mean for how we design
our technology and how we consume our
technology how about you know what role
is misinformation as a digital crowbar
uh prying us apart from the statistical
realities of our environment what role
is that playing if these flexible fluid
dynamics are part of what it is to be
well that's all that's all future stuff
and uh if you're listening to this
tonight and you think it's a cool talk
and there's something of value here then
uh that's the way i suggest starting to
think next and i'd love to hear anybody
you know here on q a but also um my door
is always open if you uh if you sort of
dig the talk and you dig the research
then definitely reach out because we're
we're always up for collaboration
okay
that's probably good for me you're
welcome
awesome
so fun and so many cool ideas in there
um anyone in the chat is welcome to
provide a question and first i'll just
pass to julian to maybe give any remarks
or
thoughts and then we'll see if there's
any questions in the chat or some
questions i've written down
no i think mark did a great job so let's
just jump straight into the q a
thanks mark
awesome um okay so
you mentioned it kind of tantalizingly
at the end about how we would
differentially be using the technology
and
that just made me wonder like what would
inactive inference
social media look like or how would
somebody of course not see any examples
of it out in the wild how would we even
go about imagining that kind of a system
anybody else want to try to answer first
because i've got something to say if
anything comes up
should i just should i just go
yeah
yeah i mean it's a good question it's
something i'm really interested in um
maybe one thing to say is uh
you might think that uh there's a big
market for making tech
that uh reduces our option set
um you know um that oh well this tech is
great for us because it simplifies our
affordance landscape and that's what
people want they want a sort of
simplified affordance landscape and the
danger is is that actually we're going
to be attracted to that because it's
going to temporarily reduce free energy
faster than we thought it would right
google does a great job of
quickly minimizing our uncertainty about
various topics but over time uh you can
have a sort of nasty outcome and i think
we're starting to see that more and more
where you collapse because it's so
rewarding to come to one place like
you know your smartphone ends up being
one place to come again and again and
again and over time your affordance
landscape is collapsing it's
increasingly collapsing to one and only
one end it's a little bit like walmart
you know it you know you want to buy
there because you can get great deals
but the problem is is that when the
whole community buys there and all the
mom and shop complexities go out of
business uh then you're stuck just with
walmart and then they put up their
prices it's a little bit you know it's
sort of like that you think that the
collapsing
uh tech is going to be good for us but
actually over time having less
complexity is harmful for us and think
about social media platforms as well
like you sterilize social interaction
and it's really rewarding at first
because social interaction is hard it's
a complex affair you know it's very
uncertain how to manage it to be with
another human so temporarily online
interactions can be really really
rewarding because they're so much
simplified but if you hang out there for
too long and you lose some of your
ability to
engage with complex human affairs um
then we're starting to see some of the
ramifications of that sort of technology
i mean we're literally
dying of loneliness even though
we're more
superficially connected than we've ever
been and i think that would be an
interesting project is to start thinking
about
what is working when we have complex
ecosystems of social interactions that
we're losing by just using social media
platforms for our social interaction
yeah julian
yeah so i was thinking about uh
intellectual humility as this is
something we've been talking about
before and
how important it is to
be open to prediction errors if you're
going to get the most out of social
media
so you can think of
filter bubbles as a kind of psychotic
markov blanket in a way and that
there is insulation from any evidence
that doesn't
match with your
your predictions or match with your
expectations
um
so in order to flourish
to to live well with social media
perhaps what's necessary is
is this kind of openness to
uh other contradictory points of view
um
uh what the ancients would have thought
of as humility
and we need to foster that to be well
with technologies
so inis what do you think about filter
bubbles as an example of
a psychotic markov blanket do you think
that's a stretch or does it fit with
your
the way that you describe this this
insulation from sensory evidence that
happens that can induce a kind of
solipsism
right
yeah absolutely i think it's uh exactly
on the right track um actually uh the
way that algorithms are constructed to
deliver precisely these bubbles in
social media
it's so interesting because it's
precisely what's going to happen a
psychological markov blanket because
it's just going to be insulated from
that amount of information making
inferences about that
that precisely precise information
without having any other
contact or exchange outside of the
bubble so that
that's very interesting as well and
there are many many other forms of
psychotic markov blankets that you can
find in the societies and communities
and um that kind of thing
um
but i didn't want to address exciting
things about the concept that it's scale
free
so uh now you see it at collective
levels of self-organization not just
but also the level of the cell you show
so that nmda receptor you can also think
of in terms of
a
yeah psychology yeah
yes i didn't have time to present that
here uh because uh yeah but um but
that's that's also formulated under the
disconnection hypothesis
by carl so it's also really cool because
it's at a cellular level so it's quite
interesting if anyone is interested so
that would be also
what we are um applying or looking at in
the in this paper is another example of
a psychotic markup blanket where there's
a an imbalance between um
again what i was saying the sensory in
the active states formulated there um as
the receptor so and specifically for
schizophrenia but then you can scale all
of these up and find all of these
psychotic markov blankets um in many
different levels and i think that in the
case of social media the bubbles are an
excellent example
but i think that we also have that as
mark was mentioning and i always i
always find it's very interesting uh
when we discuss this topic about um
about how um
specifically um the
city living
as an environmental
daily living space
influence
mental health and
and
and specifically
why and when some groups of individuals
thrive in an urban setting so this is
something that some people here in
amsterdam for example are working on and
it's really interesting um and i think
that it becomes even more interesting if
we come for example from
studies in neurodiversity for example in
autism and that kind of thing and if we
think about the design of these spaces
um daily spaces daily living spaces that
um are not designed for example for
diverse ways of interacting with worlds
such as an autistic
interacting with the world so i think
that um it is very relevant to think
about
these
mental problems and how we can inform
interventions in the city planning and
also
smart environments um
that would allow a more diverse way of
interacting with the environment as
opposed to reducing the complexity of
the environment which is exactly what
mark was talking about and i just wanted
to add that um to that
yeah we're actually working with a
pretty cool group through the nested
minds network um developing models of
anti-fragility and what we're calling
tropophilia which is the love of
uncertainty so you're not just growing
from volatility but you're actually
seeking volatility in order to grow and
we're thinking about it at the level of
communities so um we're still just
getting started but um it's a really
fascinating really fascinating field
yeah so one comment on that and then a
question from the chat um julian you
pointed out that active inference as a
scale free and sort of uh base system
agnostic framework really helps draw out
these similarities across systems and
then mark in the in the presentation you
talked about neural ecosystems about
social social media ecosystems and then
thinking about some of these pathologies
or perceived pathologies in an ecosystem
case i mean imagine if someone said i
like this tree this should be the only
tree or i'm seeing a little tension here
with a predator and the prey we should
separate those two species
those would lead to a catastrophic
collapse because it wouldn't be the frat
it wouldn't be the anti-fragile
ecosystem that
was the one that had made it all the way
to the present moment and was existing
far from equilibrium so it's sort of
like when we can look across systems it
gives us a new way to look at the
systems that we can modify the nisha of
like our cities the internet and then
starts
hopefully shining some light on where we
can look
here's the question from the chat dean
wrote remark
a simple provisioning rule
when in doubt zoom in
comma zoom out so that's dean's
providing that is sort of like a little
simple uh motto
as an attending strategy could this be a
happy person setting up a local or
global non-isolating markov blanket like
how do we go from these mathematical
framings and some of these aerodynamics
into nice slogans like dean does
no i love that i mean right yeah exactly
yeah look look close and look far i mean
that's that sounds like that sounds like
super good advice
um a little bit you know this a little
bit follows on from the same point
julian was making earlier about virtue
about some of the like what would the
virtues be
uh
relative to this kind of good updating
system and um i've been meaning to do a
i've been meaning to write something on
this for a long time now and you know
i'm getting more and more motivated as
we go along but have you ever heard of
super forecasters have you heard of this
it's a book out called super forecasters
so there's people around the world who
go to competitions and they predict
things from noisy data sets and you can
train in it and you get in a team you
can do individual events and people can
get better so you can train to be a
super forecaster so you take noisy data
you get good at predicting it and i like
this idea because i think it's a nice
metaphor you know i think we might be
able to glean like if we're all
predictors
and we're trying to predict well then
maybe there's something to learn from
people who try to predict well as a
hobby you know and try to see like what
are they doing right um and there's some
really interesting things that they do
uh that i think are um
useful given the kind of framework that
we're proposing here a couple of them i
think just everybody should know about
one a super forecaster across the board
the best the best super forecasters in
the world they share a couple of common
traits they are curious
so they're always interested not just in
their own field but they're interested
in lots of field they tend to be
polymaths so they're interested in lots
of different sorts of things that's one
thing the second thing and this is a
little bit i feel like is related to
this zoom in zoom out point and also
exactly what julian said is that they
have they have they hold so this active
inference language but they hold
high-level beliefs
that all of their beliefs are only
relatively right
so
um
they know that when they're looking at
something not to get too enamored by it
because it's up for updating at any time
so they're always checking it against
the other things they know they're the
kind of person that when you meet them
in public and you tell them something
they don't know they don't lock down and
say no no i can't be like that no no you
know they're the kind of person who says
wow wow i didn't know that tell me more
about that so i can update i can update
my overall model
relative to how the world is
anyway i think i think these like
this this approach to zooming in and
zooming out sounds just right and i
think it's so cool to start thinking
about what some what are some of the
practical virtues that would help us not
get stuck and i think uh yes
follow up on that so yeah i think what
you just described to the super
forecasters is
something that goes back to the ancients
again the peronean skeptics who put
forward the idea that we shouldn't
do we shouldn't endorse a
proposition but nor should we withhold
our endorsement we should rather try to
find this balance
and what you're describing with the
super forecasters with that kind of
hybrid project i think is exactly that
same kind of
uh
balance well that's the paper peyronian
skepticism
through the lens of active inference
that's
realm it made me think about skepticism
and like almost like a bayesian stoicism
like okay the info has come in through
the channel it came in from i would like
to learn more i will marginally update
like that sort of approach and then also
another
dialectic that you brought up that it'd
be interesting to hear a little more
about is that hedonic short-term
happiness
versus that um the eudemonia the longer
term happiness just like that's super
fascinating to see how
you mapped
two pillars of philosophy really going
so far back
and
integrate them in in a new way like
where do we go from there how do we
think about these kinds of cool
synthesis between philosophy and
computational dynamics
i love that julie do you want to say
anything on that
if not i could maybe start and you could
follow on what do you think yeah so uh
the way we were thinking about it was
though to take i don't know if mark did
this example in the talks i had to pop
out but the computer game example did
you go through that mark yes exactly you
know you might you might find a
a computer game that gives you just the
right amount of challenges to keep you
constantly
making progress in
playing the game
but still in the rest of the person's
life
going to school
uh having your friendships grow
your family life all of these things
could be suffering
so
they're just finding local pleasure
which we can assume the computer game
might continually give the person
by presenting them with this constant
challenge
in the end wouldn't be conducive to
flourishing for that person because all
of the other aspects of their life that
are also valuable and important to them
would end up being neglected
so thinking about that from a a
dynamical or a computational perspective
it seems what's important
is a kind of psychological flexibility
or
and that
you're able to
be poised between
exploiting and exploring
so the person who's playing the computer
game is really just stuck in a kind of
exploitative mode
where
that's continually
um
yielding something rewarding for them
because they're continually presented
with challenges that they can solve
but at the same time they're not
exploring they're not curious
and so there's not that kind of
psychological flexibility which we think
is required for
eudaimonia or
really living a good life and
flourishing as a person
and so we think what you get out of
active inference then is is a
neuro computational frameworks a
biological story but also a
computational story
about uh what it might be to to as a
person live a good life
what might be required is this kind of
openness and flexibility
yeah yeah it's great
two other quick things on the tale of
that one is
you know there's a very old debate about
higher and lower hedonia
yeah the low hedonia is the sort of
animal life that causes all the problems
higher hedonia but there is higher
hedonia that leads you to whatever the
good life is that's kind of interesting
from this perspective as well because
you can think about it i think maybe
as lower hedonia is aerodynamics in
niches that lead you away from the sort
of metastable attunement
right so drugs of addiction is a good
example of lower hedonia because it's
good prediction error slopes
but they're only local at the expense of
your more integrated
holistic optimality
of governing
state right but what would a higher
hedonia be well it would be a local good
slope
that leads you to a greater integration
so at the tail end of our paper and i
didn't mention it here because it's a
bit of a further topic but we suggested
maybe thinking about zero sum and
non-zero sum activities and their role
in producing or
restricting these sorts of metastable
attunements and i think that's a good
example where you can get you can get
hot about some small thing that reduces
your dynamicism so you get this global
rising in air even though you're locally
succeeding that's a nice i think it's a
nice way to think about lower hedonia
higher hedonias local good slopes that
encourage and expand and and generate a
richer and more complex uh ecosystem of
good slopes in your life so for instance
like
well like think about the things that
are endlessly rewarding
you know love
relationships you know like you're never
going to get to the end of being a good
husband or wife you're never going to
get to the end of being a good older
brother or being a good dad good mom
you're never going to get to the end of
those that's that's an endless thing or
patience patience compassion love
you know sympathy empathy i mean you're
never going to get to the end of those
things service service to the people
into your community service is such a
good example here if you feel good like
if you get good slopes in serving your
community you're just going to keep
creating more connections
that are going to create more
opportunities for new kinds of slopes to
be caught and encouraged so i think it's
it's perfect almost you know it's a
local slope that leads to lots more
other stuff and just one other quick
thing and i won't i won't i won't harp
on about it but
uh and i think also that uh a system
that's set up to be
uh to have this more global aerodynamic
regime working correctly i think they'll
also tend to have more subjective
happiness
and it would be good to like go through
this and build a
detailed computational model because
this part is just a little bit
speculative but it seems to me that if
you have a really rich diverse ecosystem
of good slopes then if you reach the end
of some particular slope like let's say
you lose the video game if the video
game is the only thing you have
no wonder we have a problem regulating
our emotions if you know you see this on
youtube all the time you know mom or dad
turns off the system and there's an
explosion and they say so this is the
only thing i have right so you're very
very rigid you're very fragile with only
one outcome but if you have lots of
stuff going on in your life then if you
lose a good slope here it's just a
matter of task switching over to the
next good slope and so i tend to think
that people who have a diversity of good
slopes in their life of course they're
also going to have
more persistent more pervasive good
feelings
but you know that's a bit speculative so
love the look
this local global nested slopes descent
i think it really helps us understand
active inference but also understands or
helps us understand how to apply active
inference because it doesn't have to be
an active inference model about emotion
but that's the one we're talking about
but it could be some other kind of
active inference model so kind of just
two other um concordances i guess
uh cezanne mahali's flow and flow
psychology it's like you mentioned
selecting the right kind of errors and
so it's like there's there's being in
the flow state of playing chess or of
doing a skill and then there's like
getting the rock out of your shoe it's
like you're you're still in this sort of
uncertainty regime but one of those is
just delaying you on the journey and the
other one kind of is the journey so that
and then one other
it's dead on it's dead on actually john
verveigh at the university of toronto
and i are planning a paper
using this exact model to think about
flow as cascading cascading insight so
every time you reduce you hit that good
slope and then you learn that's what the
good slope is you're learning and when
you get to the end of that learning what
it does is it opens up a new good slope
that you learn down which opens up a new
good slope which you learn down and that
happens in a sort of cascading a
cascading pattern yeah i love that
so that that
perfectly comes to the second example
the cascading insight like so many
people whether they're in academia or
just curious about something
when they get a quote answer they say
well you know just brought up so many
more questions like now i know how much
this planet is in diameter but now i'm
curious about something else and so it's
like that that short term minimization
is like disciplinary research like we
had 25 efficiency on this chemistry
extraction we got the 27 it's a local
who could who can say that's not a local
improvement but then that global
is the transdisciplinary understanding
and as the research ecosystem if we just
dove down local disciplinary rabbit
holes we would end up with just a wreck
but at the same time we do need to do
some local gradient descent otherwise
we're not extracting that compound so
what can we build our transdisciplinary
theory on and so it's just like
very cool how we can um have a positive
um i don't know can it be neutral and
positive at the same time
yeah yeah why not yeah it's positive in
the sense that it's not negative uh i
but i i love that and i think that's a i
think it's a role that philosophers are
increasingly um playing you know
what you might call synthetic
philosophers um philosophers who are
trained in various scientific
disciplines the neighboring scientific
disciplines around a certain topic like
dan dennett you know who are able to
zoom out and create good overall
frameworks that sort of uh that bring
together various disciplines as well as
the special sciences that zoom in that
zoom in and uh discover locally they
come in on this because i think one of
the interesting thing is the three of us
here are all philosophers so
we will come at active inference through
philosophy
but through trying to do that synthetic
kind of philosophy where
we're integrating philosophy with
neuroscience with biology
and
so that's a common theme and another
thing that i think is interesting among
the three of us is that we're all
thinking about active influence as
something that
is environment involving so one of the
crucial interesting things i think in
innis's work on
the psychotic mark off blankets is what
happens when you are
you're you have a
a free energy minimizing system that's
insulated or isolated from
what's coming in from the environment
and how that can induce pathologies
and a lot of the things we've been
talking about today are about kind of
designing an ecosystem
where
being in that kind of environment would
help you to flourish as an individual so
what would uh how would you need social
media to look
if it was instead of creating
the kind of social pathologies that
we're seeing today
with the misinformation problems and
all of the problems that are arising
from polarization you had a a social
media environment in which people
flourish
and so we think that
these ideas about active inference
if you have a philosophical perspective
on them you can see how they
they could
help you to
know to think about ethical questions
maybe political questions as well
it's about synthetic perspective that
philosophy can bring
helps you to see how to
to take this framework and
and
show how it can be applied in lots of
different domains
i think that was something that you
touched on daniel in one of your
observations questions
awesome man i think it's a valuable
contribution that philosophers can make
from from using these ideas
totally we see advances in philosophy
alongside and deeply interwoven with
governance and technology so here's just
one
last question i wanted to ask on that
theme unless anyone has any other
questions and this is um to and as his
section so you talked about
thinking about using active inference as
a model which was invoking this realism
instrumentalism
distinction that we had talked about in
some other streams
and i just wondered how will realism
versus instrumentalism or potentially
other philosophical ideas play out
clinically like
what will it look like to
deploy something instrumentally and say
that for example this is being supported
by a mathematical framework but that's
not what is per se happening inside of
you it's just how we're instrumentally
interacting with it i don't know just
how will that kind of a philosophical
nuance
enter into the regular protocols of
medicine or governance
um yeah um so i think that um
instrumentalism is very much aligned
with dynamical systems theory take on
cognition or on brain activity
right so it doesn't need to be something
that um
is highly mystical or that is like a
framework that we use but then what can
we do with it really like in in medicine
or in more experimental settings right
it's just that it's not um committed to
a more computationalist
account
of cognition or of the brain it's much
more aligned with for example in this
framework with the dynamical systems
theory as in the case of being
a tool that is useful to
explain and describe um
an activity of scientific interests
through some constructs that we know are
constructs that are we build for our own
scientific practice and understanding
right so that's the idea
so um
it is useful in the sense that you can
you can now put things together and make
this activity that would otherwise be a
blur intelligible in a scientific sense
by using these constructs which you can
think about it for example from
dynamical systems theory
mark was mentioning these attractors for
example which by the way um i'd like to
say something about that um
um in the case of um for example in
psychopathology there is this kind of
like fixed points or attractors that
kind of like we need to change etc we
are not saying that there is actually a
fixed point or an attractor
in the psychopathology but we are
explaining
this in this sense for our own or to
make these patterns intelligible
from a scientific point of view
right so it's in this sense that you can
use this instrumentalist account to say
that
you gain explanatory attraction but
you're not saying that actually there is
a fixed point in the behavior itself
does this help
yeah i think so i mean if someone looks
at an economic model and it uses a
regression it's not saying the economy
is a regression but then there's
something about
the the personal nature of the brain and
our emotions
where it feels almost like a model of
emotion or emotional dynamics
it's something that's been brought up
many times i mean a lot of people like
qualitative perspectives on these topics
because it
it averts this whole discussion on
whether the mathematical models are real
or instrumental and it almost feels like
now with that philosophical clarity
to be able to frame the two different
modes we have there we can distinguish
very clearly
instrumentalism from a sort of
background of
implicit realism and then that would
maybe help speak to a broader set of
people who have different beliefs and
different structures for what they think
is the underlying system
can i comment on this briefly yeah
please
yes i i think i take a different
perspective reminisce on the realism
instrumentalism issue
so i i start from the cybernetic idea of
the good regulator theorem that ashby
put forward and
i think that gives us a way of thinking
about how values are actually built into
living systems
and so the idea of being a model of the
environment it's not just having a model
but actually being a model
and how you can be a good model
so what does it take to be a good model
while there has to be as much complexity
in the model as there is in the
environment that you're interacting with
so i think what we get out of there
um
out of ashby's good regulated theorem is
an idea about what it is to be
well adapted to the environment
and i don't take that just to be like a
model of
uh of life or of systems that are well
adapted but that we can actually get
some principles that tell us how would a
system need to be organized in order to
be well adapted
um and those principles yeah i mean they
are a model i agree
but they actually tell us something
about
the
organization that a complex adaptive
system would need to have
if it was to remain well adapted over
time so if it was to be a good model
and then we can get some kind of value
or normativity out of that because
notice that there's a notion of goodness
implied here that we're thinking about
what would it take for a model to be a
good model of its environment for it to
remain well adapted when there's a kind
of value or normativity implied there as
well
so i think all of that is not just there
about you know finding
explanatory models that
do
a good job for us as scientists but
it's also telling us something about
what it is to
to be alive
to be
a good cognizer
so that we could begin to get some kind
of values out of biology
and i take that to be a kind of realist
project
and
because
you know i think that
we can
we can get some motion or value
ourselves
free energy minimization in fact i think
the notion of free energy is itself a
kind of value for a system that tells a
a system what it is to and to be well
adapted it's well adapted if it
if it is first of all minimizing free
energy over time but we saw from marx
talking from our paper that on its own
isn't sufficient
you need in addition this kind of
maintaining less stable poise
uh so now all of that is just to say
well i think we can get some
um
some something more than just a model
out of free energy free energy principle
we can get
some principles which help us to make
sense of how there could be values in a
in a world of facts
and so it helps us with that question it
may help us to understand
you know
what it is to live a good life so
and how could you have
natural systems that flourish
so we could get some kind of
um naturalistic account of
uh of ethical values
now so that would be my take on it and i
think that's kind of different from from
instrumentalism a different kind of
perspective on instrumentalism i think
you can also get out for free energy
principles
there's a debate here isn't there and
that's one of the things that philosophy
can bring in there's different
perspectives you can have on
what the free energy principle means
and then we can fight about that amongst
ourselves as philosophers
great closing point we respect and value
the uh
the content but then also there's that
hyper philosophical prior that the space
for the debate and the space for
different perspectives is itself
important so with that
thanks to all of you this was an awesome
session you're always as well as anyone
else welcome to come back share any
other exciting research or questions
so
great times and i hope everyone watching
live and replay appreciate this great
session so thanks again everyone and
see you next time thank you for having
us thanks so much daniel thanks everyone
thanks so much